salma lleva a sus hijos a una excursión
familiar muy especial
es la primera vez que vinimos a la
exposición estamos orgullosos de nuestro
país
vinimos de abu dhabi y reservamos un
hotel y esta mañana nos despertamos
emocionados acabamos de prepararnos y
llegar a que la idea ya vendría tri
javier uno de los países más ricos del
mundo los emiratos árabes unidos
gastaron más de siete mil millones de
dólares para convertir este tramo de
desierto en cuatro kilómetros cuadrados
de infraestructuras futuristas la sede
de la feria mundial 2020 coincide con el
50 aniversario de la creación de los
emiratos árabes unidos
las autoridades compiten por impresionar
el mundo con sus logros económicos y
tecnológicos
a pesar de esto algunas ong critican su
historial de derechos humanos con mano
de obra extranjera y la falta de
libertad de expresión
quiero decirle al mundo que somos
personas modernizadas nos gustaría que
el mundo supiera sobre uruguay
especialmente sobre los emiratos a
borders que grandes son nuestros líderes
conocido por su tolerancia
multiculturalidad aquí vivimos en paz
juntos
más de 90 países están presentes con
pabellones y delegaciones que buscan
promover su cultura y negocios para
dubai y hacer este evento internacional
es la oportunidad de estar en el foco
internacional y atraer nuevos turistas
se espera que tres cuartas partes de los
visitantes sean extranjeros